Iron Man okay so it's safe to say that
Iron Man 2 has some pretty huge shoes to
fill not only was Iron Man 1 in my
opinion one of the coolest movies of oay
but one of the coolest comic-book movies
ever made so now the expectations for
Iron Man 2 were just bigger than 2 yeah
they're enormous
and it's safe to say that any movie to
meet those expectations would pretty
much be impressive if not really
freaking difficult now Iron Man 2 it did
have its good and bad like I said Robert
Downey jr. he's just great they did some
stuff with the character Tony Stark I
wasn't really a fan of but I mean the
guy delivers what can you say
and Sam Rockwell plays an arms dealer
who's like the opponent of Tony Stark I
thought he was really good in the movie
he delivers one of the funniest
monologues in the entire movie is he
showing off a bunch of weapons I laughed
out loud props to you Sam Rockwell you
were also great Ninja Turtles Scarlett
Johansson she's pretty much the hottest
woman on the face of the planet yeah
she's gonna be on your mind after this
movie this chick old news with Scarlett
yeah and I don't feel bad about saying
that because that's the reason she was
thrown in the movie her job in Iron Man
2 is to be hot period and she does her
job well and Mickey Rourke was cool and
the scene that he did anything in his
same goes with Don Cheadle is Rhodey the
Sam Rockwell's like the bad guy in this
movie and some of the things I didn't
like
well the story does seem pretty
convoluted and I don't think it's
because of all the characters that are
in the movies all the story arcs that
are in the movie
I mean if Tony Stark were just battling
the bean counters in Washington DC and
trying to keep the Iron Man suit out of
the hands of the arms dealers I mean
that would have been just fine right
there but there are about four to five
other plot lines that Tony Stark's
dealing with in the movie also it just
makes it feel well cluttered I mean look
at Ironman one Ironman one was the story
of one guy with a bit of a narcissistic
nature but that's why we love Him who
finds out the dark side of the business
he deals and so he makes a personal
change within himself while he's in
captivity and makes an oath when he gets
out I want to protect the people I put
in harm's way sounds good but the whole
time he doesn't lose that Han Solo ISM
that makes him him he's like Han Solo if
Han Solo was a billionaire weapons
expert but in one of the overly abundant
story arcs in Iron Man 2 he shows Tony
Stark being all self-destructive and
drunk you know it's kind of pathetic to
watch you just watch it you're like Tony
Stark there's a respect for Tony star
that Tony stars that Iron Man it's like
Iron Man's drunk
douchey stepbrother twice removed
and I will say this now even though I
know I'm going to get comments about it
later I know that this is a story arc
that's dealt with in the comic books and
I know that there's a story-based reason
for it happening in the movie I'm just
saying watching Tony Stark the character
that we all loved and connected with in
the first one all down in the dumps in
the dark part of his life all
self-destructive style for an hour and
45 minutes it's just kind of a drag and
yes I know that in sequels the character
needs to be challenged in ways that he
wasn't challenged in the first one but
you can challenge him without making him
kind of douchey that's all his attitude
in this movie is that he doesn't give a
and because of that you don't
either
it's all I'm saying and okay now the
dialogue there are scenes where the
dialogue is well written and well
delivered in this movie but then there
are other scenes where the dialogues
being delivered at the same time like
two people are talking at the exact same
time it just feels like this why are you
listening to me art about you okay then
go to the press conference you know you
can have a go to the cigarette or
Ironman all right you knee thing going
on where oh and in dark you can't have
high sign oh my god all right listen to
me right that's what I have another
block that she's crazy all right oh my
god I got you I got you I got I got I
got you the climax of the movie was cool
we all saw it in the trailer of a war
machine iron man just thrown down with a
bunch of mechs it was cool fun exciting
until it abruptly ended in a 45 second
fight with the main bad guy so I won't
tell you not to see this movie that
would be impossible everyone's gonna see
this movie you have to after watching
Iron Man 1 and it's not horrible it's
not like spider-man 3 or anything it's
just not like spider-man 1 to x-men 1 to
learn man 1 either the Nolan Batman's
better than x-men 3 I think whereas the
first one stands out you think cool
comic book movie or cool comic book hero
you think Iron Man but in a world where
sequels are rarely as good as the
original this one's just kind of par for
the course so it's a fun movie that's a
bit convoluted and if you're skeptical
about the movie because the studio made
Jon Favreau rush it out in two years
instead of three which actually did
happen then it might just be what you
expect but if you're thinking right now
okay but what movies does this Jeremy
guy like what movies doesn't he like is
he a total douchebag i watch my other
videos by clicking here